got to know certain prisoners there was
with them one guy gave him up my my my
address and he was turning to be very
gay and was was very thuggish black guy
strong very gay even gave him a phone
number why would you because he was so
nice to me he was so nice to me and he
called me and wrote me letters for six
years and I'm not talking at one point
he got me he goes man I want to see you
man I want to look at you I just sent me
a picture any pictures I don't give you
give me send me a picture I'm like I'm
not playing dumb he goes I want to see
you a little man I want to see you can
you dance or look like a goddamn good
you got good-looking 35 you're a
good-looking 36 he wanted a dick pic so
badly this is before you can do it on
your phone to send him a god he asked me
to describe what what I was I was
hitting and what I was wearing and I was
like all right man and I kept going man
you know I'm just with my girl so I
can't really do that but anyway my girl
and I I mean I gotta eat the next
hamburger you like a real Apple girls he
didn't give a [ __ ] then he like gave of
the Brisbin then he like told me he's
got an AB and he won't start a band
called all in and it would be sang me he
sang me did me a song like this she gave
me a song and I'm not exaggerating and
it was this and I'm not kidding his and
it was just like a terrible I was like
boy sing better and I'm not a singer you
have a collect call from Miami girl
it's your white boy girl that's going on
I had a gay relationship I had a care
relation him with a guy who killed
several people what his crimes were they
were not good I'll kill this guy kill
this first guy 15 done fuck-all don't
don't [ __ ] my life up wow man you good
dumb [ __ ] my life up then then I don't
[ __ ] my life
yeah what I'm doing here yep he just
wanted to get a diamond stud in his nose
but they're not letting them and it was
a problem I was like okay I could send
ya how about I smuggle a diamond stud in
my ass and let my bum you're just trying
to please people so your friend like we
do them and I fly to Florida man I get
this guy won't quit harass me how about
I take it I'm dating about a diamond for
moms in and out it was flying in and out
man
and I'll take care of it he's a good guy
kept that relationship going on for
about six years court captain kept
another relationship going on for
another guy for another 10 years so it's
and oh and asked me if I sent him money
you off all the time all the time you
buy stick I'm an [ __ ] I don't know I
can't [ __ ] awesome yeah the world's
like that when we were I don't know how
to make a dip sex lower walking down a
band that homeless going to hug me oh
yeah what the [ __ ] you doing man I go
like this and get like oh what's up man
I'm like Brian what are you doing this
right yeah that's right because he
recognized yeah right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]